It was hot because I took a [Music] storm people from his house
Osman gol ya buying turkey Ezo
bay Life treyd agusto wonder video Frozen volt
also be just Allahu Han my son
who came from your Turkish
I swear by Allah you finished this couple, as you know, you finished your strength like you are right
if you don't
subscribe to
[Music]
but
one case came to you, we went and it's over,
you're fine, the world came, No,
there was a wall, he said, OK, I'll get it, he said OK, will he
hit me back in conformity?
Did we rust in Siberia at this fibrous time Fatma Ottoman
Minister of all the event Facebook To see
if there is Facebook for mon0 Mouse people
final Herbal
video mortar or
for the Directorate of your shooter filled one for Heavy
Kartal Did you die
LOL mortar the tooth of the ceiling The league is
comfortable raw  Take the motif out, don't
listen to Tahir that I bought.
What was mine, fish
for it, Dilan service is healthy, they
are fighting in platinum, there is a ceiling separate
bin today
I've been in Şahin type safe for years weak TRT full blushes
will not be too long we knead this Hot for in
Other New Hürriyet Do I have a top?
Subscribe Subscribe
[Music  ]
subscribe